so how'd you like to be Carter Paige the
former Trump campaign adviser was spied
on by the Obama administration people in
the media a lot of them have repeatedly
suggested he's a Russian spy
they were egged on and that by
politically motivated leaks from our own
government from the DOJ despite all of
that Paige has never been charged with a
single crime no crime and there's no
indication he ever will be now thanks to
this declassification order we've been
telling you about he will finally get to
see why the Obama administration spied
on him
Carter Paige joins us I always have the
same thought every time I see which is
if I were you I'd be very bitter I can't
imagine the money you spend your
reputation has been sullied to put it
mildly all these people calling you a
Russian spy but you're not better why is
that well you know things could have
turned out so much worse if President
Trump had listened to this fake Intel
report from Comey clapper Brennan in
January 6 2017 imagined the potential
wars and conflicts that it could have
led to sure and he's a massive so what
do you expect to learn from these
declassified documents I think it's it's
just going to be a complete
laughingstock
you know this is every premise anything
that I was ever asked by members of
Congress the FBI various other
government institutions it was all just
preposterous from the very beginning so
they accused you I mean you graduated
from a military academy you're a naval
officer and they've accused you members
of Congress people in the media two
whole TV channels every day accusing of
betraying your country how does that
honestly how does that feel well again I
think thankfully we have president
Trump's leadership you know working
through in terms of you know with the
the impact it's had on him and his
administration compared you know this is
a minute minuscule problems that I've
had to deal with so this is uh well you
either have deep religious faith or
you're on xanax or something because I
can't you even this of your temperament
is is amazing to me if there's one
question in 30 seconds that you want
answered that these documents may answer
what would it be
well who's responsible for all this
there's obviously a lot of people that
had some culpability but let's see you
know who did what to whom and I can't
wait to find that out it's gonna be
hilarious I had a dollar for every time
someone has sat on the set and accused
you of betraying America on behalf of
Vladimir Putin I would retire it's it's
really I don't even know you just for
the record we've died outside the studio
we've never even met but I'm just
unprincipled I'm offended by what's
happened to you we'll get part of page
Godspeed Thank You Tucker for everything